hello to everyone so just for you to
know that the ultimate G community of
practice of the CJ a platform for big
data and agriculture started the webinar
series about the ontology product of the
members of our community of practice we
want to know about the content and their
current use in key applications of
platform so the objective is to increase
the knowledge about what's the current
statutes of ontologies in agriculture
how they are developed what is their
content and also they up stimulate some
collaborative creation and additional
uses so today Maeda
maja Angelique and the Saleen will
present the agronomy Orochi about
management practices and why it was
necessary to develop this ontology and
how it is currently developed and how it
is used in the context of the global
economy shall be cool ago Pheebs great
Thank You Elizabeth first we're gonna
start off with Maeda Davari
she's gonna present she is representing
if pre she's a senior fellow research
fellow and module lead at the CGI our
Big Data Platform for agriculture over
to you Maeda
Thank You Man so I leave the the
organize module of CG ARS Big Data
Platform
and the module is all about as you might
guess organizing data and getting data
to be both open as well as useable by
other people so what are some of the
questions that that we might encounter I
mean it's always good to start from what
the what the issues really are so some
of the real real life questions that
we've encountered or you know something
like this what does variation in crop
response to fertilizer look like for
sub-saharan Africa I need data for my
crop model where am I going to find that
I want to predict land-use change
between 2030 and 2050 at both national
and sub-national level in South Asia or
anywhere in the world really where do I
go for that data well now we have
through the big
platform we have a data portal called
Guardian which looks across all of CGI
our centers as well as several other
entities in the agricultural domain
including USAID USDA the World Bank some
a portion of the world bank's data
assets the the government of India's
open data portal the agricultural part
of that and a few other entities as well
so when you do a search like this in
Guardian what you'll see is a bunch of
hits on publications and data sets I've
clicked on the data sets link here so
you can see some of the data sets that
are coming from you know a bunch of the
CGI our centers as well as USDA here but
you'll also see data depending on the
searches that you're doing as prevention
from from the World Bank from the
government of India's open data portal
and for agricultural research that data
is coming from ICA are the Indian
Council for agricultural research u.s.
aid did USDA and that list is growing as
we develop Guardian more and more so the
the issue about finding data is a little
bit better in hand now you can go to a
one-stop shop you can find data we're
still working on Guardian we continue to
improve it so we're getting to that
point where we're creating a knowledge
base for the data now when you find the
data what does it look like this is data
a very very well described data set of
that I I found from Guardian and even if
it's well described what you see is you
know some some questions about what
these gaps are in these in these cells
some of the notations that keep changing
and some of these are described in the
data there are data variables there's a
tab a metadata tab for this particular
data set and you see that for most data
sets that is still sort of a mystery you
know if you're an agronomist you might
be able to guess what these things are
but not always you continue on down the
data set these two four columns the
fifth or sixth column are still you know
question marks the
rotation is continuing to change and as
you keep moving down the data said this
is about 8,000 rows of data for multiple
countries in Africa again now you see
the notations changing so here it looks
like there's intercropping with pigeon
pea that was intercropping up above in
the data set that wasn't noted the the
treatments or what seemed to be
treatments are also changing and they're
all noted very differently even where
there are commonalities and this is just
one dataset across different countries
presumably with different people
collecting that data what's interesting
is the language changes as well within
the data set so while a lot of this as I
said is well described the notations are
well described even for this data set
not all of it is so even though you can
find the data can you actually reuse it
can you actually understand what that
data is telling you so the question is
how do I collect or find well-described
data for model simulations that won't
involve months of pain in terms of
trying to contact the owners trying to
understand what that data is trying you
know saying what those variables are
trying to tell you you might need
standardized data to recommend your best
bet intensive sustainable
intensification possibilities you might
be told as as CGI our scientists are
increasingly told it's great to make
your data agronomic data fair fair
meaning make it findable accessible
interoperable and reusable that means
adhering to the fair principles well how
do I do this just give me the tools to
do it tell me how to do it and maybe I
will so these are the kinds of issues
that we're trying to address through the
project that we're going to describe the
three of us are going to describe today
I've already shown you Guardian we're
trying to get semantically enabled data
that's where the ontologies come in that
you'll be hearing about today to be able
to query the vast data pool that is
represented in the knowledge base that
Guardian is in addition to that we're
building Fair workflows into the
Guardian data ecosystem so that whether
or not
you choose to put your to make your data
available to us we would like to make
available tools that allow you to more
easily make historical data fair or data
that's not collected use it using any
fuel books
so that's part of that cog there but
what we're going to be talking about
today and what I'm going to be
describing in a minute is how to
generate data that's already
semantically enabled so this is a
standardized data collection tools part
of it which in for the agronomy domain
is called Agri films or the agronomy
field information management system I'm
an agronomist myself and so this is very
near to my heart because I faced a lot
of these issues that that I'm that I've
just described what a graph ins does is
it allows you to standardize standardize
your data at the collection point so
you're not having to monkey with it
after you collect after you publish
trying to struggle with it in those
terms we have enabled digital data
collection and as well as quality checks
preliminary quality checks of the data
and statistical reports and I realized
that through all of this I did not
include a link to Agri films but I see
that Saleem has been putting it in the
chat Thank You Saleem for that and
apologies for missing that again the
whole thing that the the collection the
ability to collect data is reliant on
the fact that it's based on the agronomy
ontology and other ontology x' and
aligns with the cg core metadata schema
which has a generalized or a customized
instance of an industry-standard the
Dublin core metadata schema which is
what we use across all of our
repositories right so just diving into
the field book I'm gonna show you some
quick screens of what that looks like
you'll have to play with it yourself we
hope that it's we think it's quite user
friendly but we're always happy Selene
and I to to meet with you individually
and walk you through it in more detail
so the field book is organized
essentially based on kind of the suite
of things that you would do in the
EAL is an agronomist the first thing you
want to do is to describe your
experiment so here are some of the
screen the the fields that I've taken
from the screen that allows you to put
in your experiment details and I've just
shown you that that when you click on
any one of these drop-down things like
type of experiment there you see a list
of choices so it's wherever possible
we've included pick lists and all of the
content of those pick lists is part of
the ontology now the other things I'm
going to describe to you here there's a
number of different screens that you
step through in Agri films I'll just
focus on the site the crop the the
design part of this and the crop
measurement part of it just to give you
a flavor of what this looks like now
when you go to site the first thing
you're gonna do is try to identify where
your trials are set up so this is kind
of a drop down menu that's that's
organized by first level second level
third level fourth level fifth level
admin divisions wherever the data is
available we go down to the fifth level
admin where it's not we stop at
whatever's the authoritative source
allows us to get to so once you start
zooming in on your on your on your
location the what you see is is the the
tool fills in your lap' long information
so that's kind of helpful as well one of
the things that we probably will want to
do is to be able to take your pin and
drop it on your your site and hone in
further that way rather than having to
know the names that you you you you are
doing so that's that that'll be coming
soon
that's how you choose your site and once
you've done that you go on to to the
other parts if you're of the screen that
I showed you earlier so here's the crop
oops here's the crop part the crop
screens that you can see you can choose
monocrop into crop real a crop those
choices will can be modified as we get
more input from users we have a number
of crops already pre-loaded into the
system and more will be being made
available as we as
continue to work on a graphics it's
completely usable usable right now by
the way version one is already up and
available for you to play with so you
choose your crop this is all again part
of the ontology all of these choices
that you see and once you do that you
can go in and specify an experimental
design so we've got some commonly used
experimental designs in the agronomy for
the agronomy domain already there and
again they're part of the ontology so
that when I specify an AR CBD and
somebody else specifies the same design
and I'm you know a user who's looking
for for whatever reason I'm using for
I'm looking for certain experiments with
that have to do with weeds and bean into
crops a which is a little unusual but it
exists and a better that are set up as
are CBDs now because all of this is
already standardized I can I can get at
those at those experiments those trials
I specify my experimental unit we have
the choices of plot field and pot I can
specify the units the dimensions of that
experimental unit and I go on and
describe my design as part of the
experimental design I also want to
specify what my what the factors are
that I'm bearing so here again it's a
huge pick list with an autocomplete to
make your life a little easier so I can
choose a nutrient element type and
amount I can choose my crop in case of
an intra crop I'll choose you know I may
I may be fertilizing the crops
differently so I want to do it that way
here I've said okay I'm going to vary
nitrogen and I have two levels 100
kilograms per hectare and 50 kilograms
per hectare that I'm testing I'm
applying for each of those levels I'm
applying to applications or to split so
I'm applying the fertilizer into splits
essentially and then I can click on the
fertilizer application details or I can
add more nutrients I may have NPK sulfur
copper whatever it is we have all of
that possible for you to to add
once I click on the fertilizer
application details I get taken to
another screen that looks like this that
is actually something we're very proud
of it took a lot of work for us to get
to this stage and this is kudos to the
to the SIP development team because a
lot of this develop all of this
development really is done at sip except
for the ontology development work which
has done a diversity or the Alliance
Bioversity see at now so I'm now at the
screen where the the tool is helping me
calculate the amount of product that I
would need to add so I specify okay I
want to add 70 kilograms I've had a 70
kilograms per hectare of nitrogen and my
first split I can specify timing days
after planting the technique and the
traction as well by using these pick
lists and therefore most of these there
is an other when we have pick lists so
that I can also we try to give you
flexibility so that if your choice is
not part of the choices we have in the
ontology you can add that and at some
point we will try to build that into the
ontology that's the thinking behind this
behind the flexibility part of this so
I'm adding 70/30 split for my hundred
kilograms per hectare and I'm adding a
forty ten split for my 50 kilogram per
hectare treatment off of nitrogen I'm
adding it all as ammonium nitrate in
this case I can also specify using this
little table that you see here NPK
calcium magnesium sulfur bla bla I can
specify the the the product content so
the content of these different of these
different elements in a particular
formulation that I'm choosing to use so
we've tried to give you flexibility
there once I do all of this the the tool
will give me how much of the amount to
add and then of course it's not going
down to the level of saying okay you you
this is the amount per hectare now you
have to sort of figure out you know how
much for your plot the amount for the
plot that's coming in
next generation trying to get much more
useful information to the user per crop
measurement you want to specify what are
the different things you want to be
measuring in the field so here I'm going
to say ok this is I've clicked on the
wheat tab this is an inter crop that I'm
showing you for being in wheat and I and
for wheat I'm going to choose these
different measurements there's a number
of parameters when I choose fresh weight
and I say here I want the total
above-ground biomass including spikes I
you know I want the grain all of that is
possible as I go down through this this
screen for crop measurements I can I can
specify the units here in again we've
tried to get flexibility for people who
might have other units you know if
you're if you're working as I did in
Nepal you might have local
specifications of unit you might want to
add those at least for the time being so
we've we've tried to include some
flexibility there to encourage use for
people again drop lists wherever
possible pick lists wherever possible
with the potential to specify something
bespoke if it doesn't exist right so
what is this all of this give you once I
go through and walk my way through the
field book through the through the
system I end up with a field book that
looks like this which which has
randomized all the different treatments
that I've specified it gives me the the
plot number of the block number the row
number depending on the design I choose
it will lay this out for me it'll lay
out my treatments and then it will also
give me the the things that I've
specified for measurement so I'm showing
you here the tab that that says okay for
common being here the measurements have
specified for crop measurement for wheat
here the crop measurements are specified
these other tabs here are our
specifications through sort of the
general practices that I want my team in
the field to follow for irrigation for
weeding for planting etc so all of those
directions are essentially already coded
ontology and given to my to my team
right so once I've done this what we've
done is to work with the Katie smart
application so the Katie smart tool
which allows you to go out in the in the
in the field and collect data digitally
using either an Android telephone or or
a tablet so I can katie smart will now
accept this field book that I've created
and it will allow me to step through the
field and actually collect the data
it'll it'll give me what measurements I
have specified or or give to my field
crew if I'm not the person collecting
that the data it'll it'll give them an
indication of what needs to be collected
and when and and how many of those
samples need to be taken it'll it'll
give them an idea also of the management
scenario you know when do i or gate how
do i irrigate etc so all of that is is
codified because the field book has that
information katie smart collects it and
and you can use that in the field once
you've collected your data what you want
to do is send it back actually to a
griffons for analysis because you can do
preliminary analysis now you've chosen
your statistical design you said it's
our CBD you select your the treatments
you've specified and then you can go
through and and what you get up get out
of it is a criminal
preliminary very simple sort of
statistical analysis which you may
choose to use it's a nice word document
you may choose to use parts of that in a
publication or at at you know it works
really it's a very quick way of getting
a sense of what your data actually looks
like so this is the soup to nuts that
that we've envisioned we try to build
value in for our users by already giving
them metadata by already making this
data conformant with with the ontology
and this was really the use case
for the development off the agronomy
ontology we realized that we needed a
field book we need it's a way of
standardizing field information so that
now we can operate over large pools of
data that are described in the same way
we cannot use our big data and machine
learning techniques to do this and to
gain more insight from the vast amounts
of data that we're producing as agronomy
community really this is a soup to nuts
approach of a griffin's
and I am almost done but not without
thanking the many many folks who have
contributed to this the the people who
are in bold are the ones who have done a
lot of the work the lion's share of the
work but there have been a lot of others
who have contributed quite significantly
to this so I want to acknowledge that
and with that I'll stop and hand over to
the next speaker
Aman over to you yeah thank you so much
made up for that comprehensive overview
so yeah we'll pass it now on to marry
Angelique lepre associate scientist at
the Alliance of Bioversity international
and see at over to you thank you I'm an
you know if we weren't so in my
presentation today
I'm saving and I I mean it's not my
presentation you shared with 13 we are
going to present like the agronomy
ontology so I'm gonna present more on
the ergonomy structure and content and
how we build it and sitting is gonna
explain how to use it to annotate like
your data so just read
context or domain Amira gave a good
overview of what we wanted to do really
we wanted to have like an ontology that
will be that could be used to harmonize
like economic data and when we started
like this project there was there were a
lot of ontology that was already
existing that were relevant to the
agronomy domain Feinstein's some cover
like the cod Museum and thoughts on the
environment but really there was a big
gap in terms of how to describe like
treatments that are really important and
also experimental protocol and this
information is really important
particularly in the context of using the
data because if you don't have this
information maybe you can misinterprets
part of the data so for instance if you
look at yield maize yield data and you
don't know that some of the he had been
collecting and already be like stress
conditions then maybe when you use a
data set I mean you can you can that can
miss to some mistake so that's really
what we wanted to do with the economy
ontology and the economy ontology now
provides like all the semantics needed
to describe like agricultural trials
that's really what we focused on from
the experimental condition to economic
parties to the implements used for this
practiced fertilizer and also to code
measurements so as I said when we
started a lot of ontology were already
out there and that were and were
covering part of the agronomy domain so
what we wanted to do is not start from
from scratch of course but what we want
wanted to do is reuse terms that were
directly relevant to to an agronomy
ontology into like the economy ontology
and being only the classes and the terms
or add only the classes and the terms
that were really like specific to the
economy domain so how did we so when we
started we started from this basic form
an ontology that is really like the glue
to to to murder and to align together
all the pieces and all this different
domain into the economy ontology because
the BFO is providing like the common
semantics that all these anthologies are
are using some
we also have used like the chemical
ontology KB for everything all the
chemical entities that we needed like
some fertilizer or chemical that I
applied during an experiment we reused
like the environment on Karrueche for
everything related to environment where
I used like the full ontology because
sometimes some food that derived of food
products can be used at 30 right so as
well we'll use the OB ontology for
everything related to studio designs and
protocols really use the pet ontology
for like qualities what we call
qualities that are really like
components that are like the main
component of like the variables that are
coding in the fields so that's gonna
give like semantics to describe these
variables we use like the plant
experimental and condition ontology
because it lists like at least a lot of
biotic treatments and going conditions
we reuse of course like the unit
ontology because as Mira said we want to
to annotate like datasets and so the
unit's exam is a big part of that and
finally because we focused like the
ontology at least for now more unlike
the plants we reuse like the plant
ontology for everything to get a
question like the prom part that
obviously do a thing like that from the
peel and we reuse like the chihwan a cop
ontology for the phenotypic traits and
and enviable that I can be recorded
during the experiment and so all of
these domain yeah integrated nicely in
the economy ontology and then we focused
our efforts on describing terms that
were really specific to the economy
ontology so now I'm gonna explain a bit
like the different types of terms that
you're gonna find in the ontology and
also how they how these terms are linked
to each other
so first the main element 3d of the
economy ontology is this notion of
magnitude to agricultural experiment our
plot so this is in the plot or that can
be like an entire feed that can be like
a product like in the
in when you have a specific design that
can be so really this notion of of plot
is where you're gonna have like all the
things happening and this brought in the
ontology so this term or class in the
ontology is linked to different concepts
so this plot is thing it's an object and
is linked of close to the agricultural
experiment it is also linked as you can
see here two things that can be measured
on that plot like like the lands or the
area so and then on that plot something
happened so you plant a cob and then you
have a certain type of of terms that we
have any ontology that are going to be
processes so you know I represent it
like a planting process and a new
process is really like everything that
is time-bound so he has a start it has
an end and then you can see on the the
the schema here that the element that
are linked to a process are defined from
the element that are linked to like
objects or entities so here for each
process you're going to find find like a
list of what we call participants so
this participant can be like tools like
you can see it or it can be like the
seed that is used like that you use all
the cop like the seed of the cob that
you use during your grunting process and
then this way you can use the ontology
to describe what is happening like
during over time in your plot then you
can have like for instance an ergonomic
fertilization process happening so this
is the the two types of terms so the
processes and then the object that we
redefine in the ontology and her all of
this is linked together so now I'm going
to get a little bit on in the economy
like the ontology structure so as I said
at the beginning our goal was to
describe agricultural experiment
so this agricultural experiment photos
like a design soil it's completely
randomized design and this economy
experimental curves and in this cycle
could draw an experimental plot so
that's gonna be like the the main
element as I said before and then
something happen also in this product
like this fertilization process
and and this fertilization process I
started to say before it cannot like
participant that are likely that is
really the two that you are using during
your 30-day the fertilization process so
here you're going to use like a manual
spreader for instance this process is
also like a different type of
participants so it's gonna be like the
fertilizer itself that you are using and
here you can see that is that this
limestone is not coming from the economy
ontology but is coming from the
environment ontology
so this is how we link like the
different domain together and then what
is really important in when we do like
this fertilization process is to know
like the the amount of fertilizer that
we're gonna apply in the field and so we
have like this you know the night you
know then fertilizer amount class in the
ontology and then that is linked also to
an external term and then to a unit so
this is like a simplified view I mean I
just created one process and even like
partially one describe one process but
this is how like how the deontology is
built an athenian is gonna explain later
how you use like the the classes to tell
your data but really once you you tell
your data what you get is really like
this entire graph thanks to the ontology
and or the semantics that is really even
between like all these these terms so
now i'm just going to give you like a
quick overview of things that you can
find in in the economy ontology so as i
said you're gonna find like different
types of agricultural experiments that
are like describe you're going to find
like different agricultural processes so
we've seen like the branching process
30 different process but also irrigation
Arvest like you know long levering
everything then you're going to find
these stuff like our actual implement
that can be used like during these
processes and finally you can you can
also find like a list of of fertilizer
like organic and inorganic fertilizer
that that can be used during like a
fertilization process and so that's just
a quick overview of
things that we have in agronomy ontology
and I really invite you to to look at
more into details of of the content
because I mean I couldn't of course like
yeah make a screenshot of everything
so in terms of maintenance so we
followed like the open zipper that are
good very good practice to follow when
you build ontology and so the ontology
is open it's like open to everyone to
contribute
it's like version control and everything
so yeah all of that is listed in the
over family point seeker that we are we
followed for the ontology building
itself we use like the Protege tool in
addition of like the ontology
development kit for dealing with all
like the ontology development kit is
like a suite of tools that we use for
instance to deal with like reusing terms
coming from external ontology in a very
like in a very easy way so we don't have
to maintain all of that like this
ontology development kit take care of
everything
so make it's very easy to to to reduce
external authorities and also to make
release of the ontology and anything
like that
and finally the ontology ontology is to
be shown on github you can find the link
here and and we use github so for the
publishing but also we have the issue
tracker on github and Cellini's gonna
explain that a bit more later and then
in terms of next steps or an ontology is
never really finished so we are still
looking at adding more content so it can
be used like Bodley and so the one of
the big tasks that we want to continue
is like to to add more units of
measurement that I released specific to
the economy domain because sovereign the
unique that that I use are currently
missing so that's really like something
that would like to address and also we
want to continue working with like the
different external ontology and
contribute to them in terms of terms
that are like 11 for the economy domain
for instance in terms of fertilizer we
are diligently we I mean we we made the
request to 2 KB to add some new
fertilizer but also we are going to do
that for involve
we cannot like more so related terms or
fertilizer even that can be be imported
than in the economy ontology and finally
we would like to to map I go with the
cassava a bar so the cassava a birds are
like variables that are widely used by
caught murderers so we started looking
at the Casa viable when viable when we
started like the agronomy ontology but
so we have some of them but now we would
like to to like have a more
comprehensive list of of this viable in
in the ontology and be sure that
everything can be map easily so then
when the data are notated using the
ontology the code module can directly
take the data and then use them more
easily without spending time cleaning
the data and all of that so yes so
that's that's all for me
great thank you so much Mary so yes we
have made it has given us a
comprehensive overview of the agro
themes and you have given us the
overview and insights into a girl and
now Selene is going to give us kind of
the link and in some of those more
specific ideas and concepts that you
referred to both in your in your
presentation so now Alberta Cellino that
who is an agro curator a guru of beams
coordinator and consultant at if
pre-high I think you a man hello
everyone
so yeah as Mary told you she has
presented in detail what is a grew and
what is its content and so now I will
tell you a bit more where to find a
group first and then how it uses so to
browse over download a grow you have
different options but the first one is
to go on the agro web page so in the web
page you will find all the information
about the ontology you have also the
contact and you have the possibility to
browse or download agro you can also go
on the ontology lookup service of EBI I
have to mention that maybe the OLS is
going through maintenance and sever
migration so by a consequent the
ontology has not been updated there
because they stopped doing updates
during mint
but everything should be back to normal
by Aprill twenties you can also use a
group bottle it's a platform the blood
by the Liam and it's gathering a
different origin in agriculture and agro
is also available in on Toby and finally
you can also go to github and download
aggro on your laptop so you can choose
the tool you are the more familiar with
and so now I will show you how you can
use OLS EBI that is well available
directly on the website of the OLS or
you can also find it on a grower web
page on the OLS you can use the search
box to directly type the term you are
looking for and so then the others will
give you a list of available terms if
you are a bit more adventurous and you
want to explore your year key you can
directly type into the ontology tree and
look at their different classes and
subclasses so here you can see the
different tillage process we have so you
don't only see the rich tool but you can
still see mulch the strip till and to
differentiate aki and on the right side
you can also see the different relation
between the classes so once you serve
like the term that you are interested in
you will have a definition of the term
with the reference to this definition
you as I say you have also the the
relation of this term with the other
classes of the anthology and you will
find a UI I so this URI is an identifier
that is unique for each ontology term
and so this is what you will use to
annotate your document your data so
basically what you will do is copy paste
this URL in your file in your excel file
or database to link your data with the
ontology
and so you will have to follow the same
schema looking in the ontology for each
term and copy pasting them in your file
for each of your term so this is quite
cumbersome and time-consuming exercise
but luckily there are some tools to help
you in this task so the first tool I
will talk about is capo you might have
heard about it already it's a portal
link to ontology that is the description
of the data of with ontologies so when
you go to capo first you upload your
file so here i've uploaded an excel file
and capo this is displaying the
different columns of my file you can see
them here so i've selected your first
column the root fresh weight and then i
go to the search box type the name of my
term and then capo will look into the
difference oncologist what is the
closest term to the one i'm looking so
you can look at the different terms and
the definition and then you select the
one that you are interested in it will
be saved here and capo might directly
make the link between this term and your
column in your file and so you do this
for all the different column of your
file and at the end you can export all
the different annotation as a JSON file
so this is a great tool to help you
annotate data file that are already
created because cocoa create the links
between your file and the ontologies
directly
if you have not yet collected your data
there is a great tool that I can
recommend to use directly at the start
of your agronomic experiment and it's
well a griffin's so midde already
demonstrated the different step to
follow to create a fill book ready to
collect agronomic data using mobile
device and so once you have collected
your data with your mobile device you
will get a file like this one with
annotation in the column headers like
here you can see you have the UI of a
group and so the annotation are
automatically done without any
additional additional work from you so
you don't need to look for each term in
the ontology this feature is currently
under development with maje we are
adding the last missing term in a grow
to be able to create this automatic link
between a graphemes and the ontology it
should be completed by the rider or in
the coming months and so this will be an
easy way to create data file that well
annotated for the data but also for the
metadata and without additional work for
you are looking in the different
anthologies
so I hope our presentation gets you
motivated to use aggro you can find a
group we have the different platforms
that I shared with you in the chat box
and so once you use a group please feel
free to send us your feedback and
ontology is a collaborative tool that is
always evolving so if you are looking
for a term and you don't find it or
maybe you'd like to discuss the new
Yaqui or provide any type of feedback
feel free to open an issue on github
issue tracker and we'll get into contact
with you so if you never use github you
can well follow the link that I shared
with you and then you go to the issues
and you will find you don't see it in
the picture but you will find here like
new issues and so then you just say in
the comment whatever you whatever your
feedback is and then we'd get in contact
with you so finally I would like to
thank the people that I have contributed
to I grow by giving us super hoods and
feedback the ontology would not be so
strong without the advice so thank you
very much for your attention and I hope
I grow and Agri films will be useful for
your research
please feel free to contact us if you
like to get some supports when you are
using them Thank You Celine and just
just for clarification if people want to
get in contact should they get in
contact with you Celine or would it be
any three of you if it's a question more
related to deontology they can get in
contact with Marie angelic and myself
and if the question is related to a
Griffins it's better to get in contact
with Smita and myself okay great thank
you so much
Celine and and so now we are at our
question and answer and comments session
for the webinar today so maybe we go to
Elizabeth for your first question yeah
thank you for the demonstration of ago
themes and my question was people they
need to create parameters or new
variables on the
priced at lots we know that so how how
do you make sure that those new
parameters and variables created in a
graphing by the users can be feedback to
the ergonomic Raji what would be the
process at currently and what could be
done in the future to make the
submission more seamless thank you so
right now the the way you submit things
that are not in that you cannot find in
in the ontology is first of all you you
try to describe something you're doing
in the field if it's not there and you
can't sort of compromise and use what
whatever is there that doesn't meet your
needs then you would choose the other
part the other the other sort of feature
of the of most of these pick lists and
add what it is that you want now once
that's added we will we will hopefully
be able to see it we haven't actually
engineered the links right now that that
provides a little alert for us or that
put that term as an automatic sort of
issue into the into the github but we're
gonna have to wait we're gonna have to
see what what is possible with the
developers if that's possible and that
would be one way that we catch what the
issue is and can get in touch with
whoever has wants it to make sure that
we understand correctly before we create
a new concept and an integral for it or
we look for a matching concept in
another ontology that we might have
missed so the short answer I guess is
that we don't have the processes already
available but we have some thoughts as
to as to how that can work and within
the next year or so we hope to to build
all of that out
there are other things that that we we
we also are trying to do that we see is
kind of very high priority in terms of
more improvements to the to the user
interface the accommodation of survey
type trials because that's something
that our users have asked of us very
large survey type trials multi
locational trials with thousands of
farmers right now Agri firms cannot
handle that very well so that we're
working on those bits first but
hopefully we will also be able to
address this issue of the feedback as we
go forward we also want to make sure
that we're not just enabling KT smart as
the digital collection tool we want to
also make sure that people can use ODK
open data kit and the field will gap as
well so that those are two pieces of
high priority development that will
happen in 2020
great think you made that we have
several more questions coming in you can
start off with a lantern bassoon my
question is from agrifim with respects
to using the KD smart data collection
tool Hadid it has been connected with
this hub how is the data obligated ready
start so the data is collected with your
KT smart application on your phone say
or your or your tablet
once you've finished collecting the data
you ship it back in the form of the
field book essentially an excel field
book back to algorithms you can do your
statistical analysis and you can either
download the data and store it locally
or you can it's stored in the server and
you can you can play with it there one
of the things that we want to also
enable is the the ability to to try and
enable sort of people to share the data
and now with the implementation of
Globus across CGR
I would like to see whether we can bring
somehow tie algorithms to to Guardian
more tightly so that the Guardian now
has CG labs collaborative Guardian labs
which allow not only searching of the
data but but secure sharing and and
transferring of data as well as
collaborative analysis of the data and
the development of scripts and all of
that so it's it's a kind of a
full-service solution and so if we can
tie a graph ends and and CG labs closely
together then that data can be stored on
the CG lab server and it'll be a secure
transfer or insecure sharing that's
that's behind that with Globus putting
the stamp on it and Globus is HIPAA
certified so that it's it it conforms to
the very very high levels of privacy
private data sharing secure data sharing
that's required in the medical domain
HIPPA has an Americans
but it basically allows you it tells you
that that data sharing will be secure
does that answer your question Busan
yes I mean yes I say have some little
concern in the sense that I know that
some scientists on some projects all
right I want to have the data exclusive
to themselves during the life span I
mean they'd like the active life of the
project until when I said we do not
mandate that the data should be open
they can do that they can download the
data and and that that will be fine you
know then it's residing on their laptop
until they choose to make it until the
choose to upload it to the institutional
repository for example but if they
choose to work in CG labs that is a
secure environment so just just CG labs
is something you know CGIAR has not
heard very much about because it's very
hot off the presses but that'll be
coming as well that webinar on that will
be coming soon great think you made that
thank you for for that question as well
though the next question is from Khaled
presentation my question is about is
there any kind of integration currently
done between your team and the breeding
management system from IPP in terms of
unify the ontology and and something
like that yeah that's a good question as
well
so so we started out actually looking at
the BMS to see if there was a way in
which we could modify the BMS in some
way to make it available also for
agronomist and and confer or not
confirmed but but you know appropriate
for agronomist but the issue there was
that the breeders are very much focused
on germ plasm whereas agronomists I
won't say they don't care about the germ
plasm but that's not the focus of what
they do it's it's more the the
management and so we couldn't find a way
to sort of make it appropriate for both
and and where the integration now is is
the fact that the ontology provides that
ability to to crosswalk across the tooth
so
there's there's the potential for once
you have the data actually then you can
sort of start to do some more seamless
integration between breeding data and
agronomic data because they're both
reliant on ontologies that's that's the
level of integration there is right now
yeah and also I would add to on that I
mean we have been discussing with the
technical team of the BMS to see how the
cue implement also the economy ontology
terms particularly on the experimental
conditioning treatments into the systems
I mean for the cop on the part on the
cop measurement they are using like the
the cop ontology so that's fine I mean
these two part are going to be more or
less harmonized between like the economy
system and and the gradient management
system so that that's good although as
me I said I mean there are some
differences but like most of the terms
that are in comment would be implement
so that's already something good but
yeah we are in discussion with the
technical team also the BMS we are the
meeting recently to to show them like
the last advancement of of the economy
ontology to see how they could integrate
that in in that system we have a
question from Eddie and so the question
is on a grow what is the percentage of
terms reused from other ontology x' how
many new entries were added into a grow
and how do you deal with updates when
other ontology x' sources of terms
change percentage rostrum is about like
75 percent of the terms coming from
external anthologies and 25 percent of
jumps coming from from from ago directly
that we we created and so yeah there
there's about like 500 something terms
that we created like but only under the
economy ontology namespace and how do we
deal with the update in external
ontology that's why we are using like
the ontology development kit
suite of tools because that make that
very easy so every time we update the
economy ontology we just make sure to
unlike the script that's gonna check
that everything is still in place
sometime we find like
you know that some update might cause
issues in the economy ontology but then
we work on fixing that but yeah at the
end by using the tools that are very
like standards and while using the Oba
community we can do that like pretty
easily so so yeah so that's how we do
like to particularly true to build like
this this list of reuse Xterra where we
want to reuse external ontology terms
and one we are one add like terms that
we we don't have so that's also very
easy we just have a list of terms that
that we want so if someone make a
request and say oh I want to add this
fertilizer for instance and but we don't
maintain really fertilizer in not gone
and it's like the inorganic one so we
will ask heavy to do it and then one
Skippy
I'd like the term then we are gonna
import it in in a go and really I mean
we did it like recently and that's
really yeah that works what well to do
like that because we cannot maintain
everything so it's easier to maintain
what is really directly relevant to the
economy domain and to let like the other
like expert to maintain like you know
list of chemicals or list of different
like by own so things like that
great thank you Mary we have another
question that came in actually through
LinkedIn chat platform and it's from
Kathy sled from data Co and the question
is I think specifically for Marie does a
grill include soil properties we are
working on a global soil information
system for file
I think soil properties is where we meet
yes so we import some so we have
a few properties in ago that are mainly
imported from the environment ontology
and I know that currently they are
working like they have a project to work
on that how to add like more muscle
properties into the the environment
ontology
so that's not something that we are
going to maintain ourselves but that's
something that we are going to be used
from this environment ontology and and I
mean be happy to two years with that the
environment ontology develop go to two
year to provide like this feedback and
and say that sometimes might be needed
and then we can like import them or yeah
we use them in the economy ontology so
so so we have them but yeah we we don't
want to maintain mokopuna stop so
properties ourselves
great Thank You Mari I don't see any
more questions coming in a lot of thank
yous thank you again for participating
and thank you again to the presenters I
think what will now do is wrap up and
again thank you to the three presenters
and those who have logged in today I'm
going to hand it back over to Elizabeth
to just let us know
what's coming next
thank you a man so thank you for three
speakers for the very interesting and
informative presentation
I think it was super useful and it was a
successful webinar given the number of
attendees this was the second webinar of
the series about the community of
practice products we have an agenda in
fact already so we hope to get you
online for the next webinars thank you
very much thank you a man and Celine who
had me organizing this webinar and
thanks again to our speakers